[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trop gentil votre maman par contre moi
je raccroche à ma mère comme ça au nez
elle me fout une panée je pense que
t'inquiète pas t'inquiète pas elle est
sympa je suis en train de gérer là et
excuse-moi oui
je veux faire ma chronique de chez moi
je vais t'expliquer ça va être simple
comme ça alors moi c'est très simple moi
j'ai toute cette partie toi tu es là
la distance
et donc du coup bonsoir à toi
les fesses alors on va commencer Cyril
avec un chroniqueur
tu me donnes mal au ventre je ne rigole
pas non non je te jure non mais tu me
ballonnes
tu me balade c'est le poids que je vous
fais ça je me balade
[Applaudissements]
très bien Jean-Michel maire c'est la fin
de la saison c'est la porte ouverte à
toutes les fenêtres je sais pas pour qui
se prend Jean-Michel en ce moment je
sais pas si c'est là ou si c'est les
années d'expérience à TPMP mais oui oui
Jean-Michel maire fracasse tous ces
petits camarades ah bon Cyril il va
falloir sévir c'est le déglingueur de la
semaine c'est un con
le déglingueur de la semaine
prochaine
alors monter c'est fait autour de
Guillaume
[Musique]
et c'est pas fini regardez vers des
saucisses pour une petite balle perdu
2 cm de Zen ils l'ont mis dans son
triple
[Applaudissements]
c'est faux en plus il a pas fait mais il
aurait dû
[Applaudissements]
oui alors vous avez vu donc Jean-Michel
est très très compliqué en ce moment
mais assez parlé de Jean-Michel j'ai
envie de parler de vous touche pas la
main
parce que vous avez l'air d'où vous êtes
d'où vous êtes d'où
vous êtes d'où et riche en même temps
dépêche-toi alors
chroniqueurs en train de te peloter sur
l'animateur excusez-moi d'être de
vouloir être proche de moi
froide comment est-ce que vous me
stressez donc je suis un peu fatigué
faudrait que tu les mettes 5 minutes
auprès de mettre une culotte chaude
de faire ta chronique merci
[Rires]
parce que moi c'est après c'est
dégueulasse mais excuse-moi tu crois pas
pendant deux heures donc non est-ce que
on peut expliquer le fonctionnement de
l'émission hôtesse spectateur il y a une
copine à moi à nous qui s'appelle
Sixtine et en gros Sixtine c'est un peu
la nounou des chroniqueurs voilà c'est
celle qui s'occupe de leur donner les
sujets etc sauf que et bien la commune
une grande erreur cette semaine Sixtine
et qui a été le premier à remarquer
cette erreur c'est Cyril bien sûr c'est
le front du collier de la semaine vous
allez comprendre pourquoi
le franc du collier de la semaine
il faut que la pauvre ça toute la
journée oui elle aurait dû vous
l'envoyer à vous et pas au chroniqueur
c'est légèrement plus importants
je vous aime beaucoup mais bon voilà
et ce qui est top avec ces chroniqueurs
bah c'est qui sont lucides
[Rires]
vous le pensez vraiment ou pas bien sûr
à ton avis je crois que oui
j'ai eu un chroniqueur ou une
chroniqueuse au téléphone ce matin et on
a des nuits qu'on pouvait faire
l'émission à 4 voir 5
je peux pas dire ce matin mais j'ai eu
quelqu'un au téléphone
un chroniqueur ou une chroniqueuse
vous discutez de la manière dont
fonctionne l'émission oui mais une
proximité qui regrettable pour le reste
de l'équipe Noël
il est producteur aussi il doit faire
des économies
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'humilité de Valérie Bénaïm l'humilité
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dû insister
on vous parlera de cette discussion
parce que ça vous concerne également
quand même
forcément on a parlé avec Valérie donc
forcément il y a Géraldine
[Applaudissements]
on s'est dit on sait pas elle le temps
qu'elle est là on en profite tu sais
c'est le secteur mais c'est vrai c'est
comme tu peux avoir de la famille à très
loin ta vieille tente tu sais jamais si
c'est la dernière fois
le risque là voilà j'ai une petite
remarque en fait vous avez fait le tour
le seul dont vous n'avez pas parlé c'est
Castaldi
mais alors je vais vous dire
je sais ce que Valérie a dit quelque
chose qui était vrai ce matin
alors
j'ai dit que Benjamin était essentiel
parce que c'était ils sont très bonsoir
à sa famille il a beaucoup d'enfants
[Applaudissements]
aime bien parler au public pendant les
pub c'est vrai ça ma chérie tout se
passe bien tout ça bon
connaissez très bien votre public c'est
l'heure de la question de la semaine
c'est quoi la base
la question de la semaine
[Musique]
ça va les chéris d'amour
je sais ce que vous vous dites je sais
ce que zip public quand il vient pour la
première fois ici salut c'est Jean-Luc
que peut se bien se dire le public quand
il vient sur le plateau TPMP réponse a
j'entends vraiment des goûts
vestimentaires de merde réponse B le nez
du Verdez Maga chez la vue toutes les
missions réponse C je me souviens plus
si Casta était là réponse d qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont chers
ils y sont beaucoup plus moches en vrai
et bah c'est vrai et bah c'est vrai
je vous le dis je veniez vos questions
on est beaucoup plus beau à la télé
qu'en vrai donc voilà tu es dedans
j'y crois pas mais par contre c'est pas
la peine à la semaine prochaine
gardez votre argent
vous inquiétez pas autre chose oui on va
encore parler de vos Cyril ah merde
alors moi je vous trouve plus beau en
vrai mais du coup tout le monde se pose
des questions est-ce que Cyril est
célibataire ou pas célibataire est-ce
que Cyril est amoureux pas amoureux bien
moi je peux vous le dire oui cyril a
craqué cette semaine
a craqué sur quelqu'un
si je vous dis belle chevelure joli
accent et trône brillant
Bertrand
Dakar je vous assure qu'il y a un bail
entre Cyril et Bertrand Deckers vous ne
rêvez pas c'est la love story de la
semaine
de la semaine
[Musique]
ça va bien les couilles
ensuite et vas-y que ça se fait des
petits compliments capillaires c'est bon
tu as fait une petite couleur
c'est plus sombre c'est quoi ça c'est un
chat chacun cendré ça
et là il y a plus en cadeau vous allez
voir ils sont à deux doigts de quel en
direct
en forme de pudding
son zizi c'est un pudding sans vie
[Applaudissements]
forcément un gros bail c'est un énorme
bague qui vous concerne également vous
savez que Cyril dans cette émission on
reçoit beaucoup les candidates de et les
candidats de et si on se rencontrer
cette émission même si ce qu'on adore
tous et c'est vrai que c'est des
candidats un peu en couleur on va pas se
mentir et on a reçu notamment Nathalie
Nathalie qui a éveillé la curiosité des
chroniqueurs qui sont vraiment on peut
le dire de grosses bits autour de la
table ce sont les Catherines et les
lianes de la semaine vous allez voir
après
oui oui ils ont peur ils ont bien raison
de la semaine
donc là Nathalie va arriver en plateau
et regardez bien comment les
chroniqueurs sont bienveillants avec nos
invités
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
un petit visuel de Joy voilà Joy bon
voilà vous allez voir qu'elle a un peu
plus intéressé les chroniqueurs et pas
que les chroniqueurs
on peut le dire les Charo de la semaine
regardez bien les têtes des chroniqueurs
lorsque Joy en grand plateau surtout une
salle de Castaldi qui monte Charo
[Musique]
Bernard aussi a été de son petit regard
le rendez-vous amoureux
ça m'a tranquille vraiment tous les
chameaux heureusement Cyril vous n'êtes
pas du tout comme ça vous êtes pas un
chaos ça avance je vais faire mon frère
oh ça va ça va
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]